the man who became a movement Jeremy
Corbyn now forced to watch as the Labour
Party he built crumbles in the wake of a
landslide conservative victory not sorry
but taking responsibility as the blame
game begins an admission perhaps that
far from healing divisions as he hoped
mr. Corbin himself divided opinion mr.
Corbin wrote in the observer we have
suffered a heavy defeat and I take my
responsibility for it labour will soon
have a new leader but whoever that will
be our movement will continue to work
for a more equal and just society and a
sustainable and peaceful world
the central question facing the party
now is where did it go so wrong some
belief brexit not policy was to blame
why should Labour not change its
policies well it shouldn't change these
policies because they are very very
popular we will now have a new leader
that new leader I suspect will come from
a new generation and we'll see where
that takes us because what Jeremy's
don't remember we are the largest
political party in Europe because of
Jeremy Corbyn but for many labour
candidates the reality was stark and it
crept in over years not weeks time and
again the leader proved the problem
voters who labor never thought it would
lose turned instead to the Tories nearly
on every doorstep Jeremy Corbyn came up
as a negative people didn't trust him
they didn't believe him people from
Armed Forces families with connections
were worried about him and that
undoubtedly was an issue they didn't see
him as Prime Minister this is a pivotal
moment for labour was it the message or
the messenger that lost him this
election would voters vote for such a
bold policy platform if someone else was
in charge or was it the decision to tack
to the left that made labor more
unelectable than it has been for decades
the answers to these questions will
define the party for years to come with
no answers yet there's no real
front-runner but Rebecca long bailey has
already won the support of John
MacDonald Lisa Nandi is seen as a strong
voice for the north of the country but
would she win the backing of Pro Corbin
members Angela Rayner has also been
talked up by Mr Macdonald as a future
leader part of the new blood of the
party
he has helped to foster Jess Phillips on
the other hand would be seen as a big
departure from the current leadership
but she worries the Tories which should
in theory
please labor both saki-sama and Emily
Thornbury are experienced and signed up
to mr corbyn's politics but are they too
tied to the old regime
the reality is Labour's next leader will
be chosen by the very movement mr. cool
been set up will those members be
willing to turn away from the project
they helped build some Labour MPs hope
they might the battle for the house of
the party has already turned nasty with
recriminations flying about the way the
leadership treated voters in the north
caroline flint speaking earlier today
about emily Thornbury she said to one of
my colleagues I'm glad my constituents
aren't as stupid as yours I'm sorry it's
not acceptable a claim denied by Miss
Thornbury who said this is a title and
utter lie I have never said this to
anyone nor anything like it and I hope
needless to say not something I would
ever think whoever leads labour out of
the Corbin years faces a battle to hold
on to remain backing city seats while
regaining the heartlands which voted to
leave and they'll do it in the shadow of
a conservative prime minister who still
can't believe his luck and is determined
to hold on to those hard-won votes
Kate McCann Sky News